russia's war in ukraine has provoked a
refugee crisis thousands are fleeing the
russian assault and heading for
neighboring countries including poland
that's where our crystal commancing is
tonight crystal
donna it is very busy here at the
shemeshill train station which has been
turned into a red cross site now some of
the people who have arrived here have
been on a journey that has been taken
almost an entire day they are tired but
they are all telling us that they are
grateful to be safe but they know their
family members back home simply aren't
the kremlin is looking to squeeze the
life from ukraine by capturing its roots
kiev
the russian invasion now laying siege to
the capital and those of the nearly 4
million residents who are left
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
says civilian sites are being targeted
and innocent people are being killed
apartments and homes devastated by
rocket attacks still many ukrainians are
standing their ground fighting for their
homeland despite being outnumbered and
outgunned including zolensky showing
himself in the streets of keith amidst
false reports he had fled
premier minister
here we are says a defiant zelinski on
the streets of keefe his message the
citizens are here and we are here we
defend our independence
zolensky may now be putin's priority
target seeking to destabilize ukraine
from the top down the president also
urging the world to act and add tougher
sanctions against russia right now he
and others say ukraine is alone
underground people seek shelter hiding
even sleeping in metro stations built to
withstand cold war attacks others have
chosen to run
the united nations estimates more than
50 000 ukrainians have already sought
safety elsewhere the majority in moldova
and poland some border crossings are now
lined with vehicles others with families
fleeing on foot in the cold
this young woman says it took her nearly
24 hours to get to poland i really don't
know what to do i can pray god to save
our hospitals and that russian will stop
bomb
ukraine
and hope my
best
my
native
people will be safe and i can
meet them again
others have tried to leave on trains
the scene becoming so frantic at times
guards fired rounds into the air to
regain control of frantic crowds many
have no choice but to stay put
and hope even as russia continues to
advance
that they'll be okay
the longer this war goes on the more
people will flee and seek safety in
places like poland and that will mean
the more services will be needed for now
there is a lot of effort a lot of help
but no one knows how long this will all
last donna all right crystal in poland
tonight thanks